and sale and go yo what's up GQ this
your boy wife and loot you on the rock
sheesh man I got a name wife and Moochie
by up on the trade town over you like
sixty rapping they got to you know doing
it life find a ways to make money I
always find a way to make some money so
he just started calling me loose I grew
up in Summer Hill and Atlanta Georgia
it's right by the bridge Stadium it's
like growing up in any other hood
already everybody trying to get out
trying to find a way of slim making
money not a go I made it out I'm gonna
start with this they would like one of
the first pieces I bought with my own
money I paid like 20,000 for just to
look home young fly nation bout cash we
was always on a flying we always know
how to go get some money back [ __ ]
other I bought the whole game somebody
1820 change it was like 85 a piece a
bachelor charm I gave one to the crew I
kept me too long oh yeah they were lit
yeah oh yeah we had a dream to see I
lost my ring but everybody else got a
ring I just recently got this I had got
man young an h1 what I ain't gonna lie
and engage um Nick the money yet so I
don't even know how much it cost and I
finna buy like the whole crew sorority
it was a gift right here from day one of
my friends
homey I wanted to see oh that's
president of thanks again he said he got
me this though he's nut that's one of my
homies he passed away like five years
ago and it was right after I dropped my
first mixtape ever I always be saying
only a nut he got me too
and they got a long little nut on the
back there you go to swing the camera
again just a small diamond chain him
like 25 point I think I paid by like
20,000 yesterday I can put them on as I
go so you can see how they look when I I
put the small chain on this one right
here it's my big 44 no I pay 50 for this
little business there right I'll pay $15
oh it's a little bigger than a little I
would tell him I do get my daughter home
from school or necklace we should make I
hate anything he actually cannot win and
she said yeah he said just don't break
it just a dirty porno I pay like for 43
years of [ __ ]
this yellow go like Rogo the most this
rolls all right here boom I don't know
the name of it I paid like 70,000 for I
did like the way it look don't you think
that's a 13 to 25 point they both the
other goal I bought both with E together
first day was Connecticut but then I got
him separated and I had page 72 both on
did you yeah mom one of my daughter's oh
yeah
range a more focus I got it for my
birthday flag a module on my budget
called for my elbows of guilt [ __ ] no
I'm going to take off autumn on autumn
off little Robo then was setting it down
yeah they white gold I paid 60 no no
same time ain't gonna spend much here
like that oh thanks little they've grown
man watch put going on they know what's
going on yeah yeah sometimes I walk to
both dick guys they got my tea my girl
white I'd be wearing a white go autumn
ah be permanent beneath in that for a
minute
ain't take them off
still one seven I thought they were like
55 100 sporting 60 side one and that was
the third that was a GILF right here my
girl got me this one resonate wife and
on the front I got lonely I'm not in the
middle that's another one I did recently
bought though over 15 I lost a diamond I
feel like my mouth and my my earring I
paid 25 oh yeah my family
no ring so face [ __ ] okay basically I'm
not gonna really buy too much more
jewelry right now I'm gonna let my
properties catch up to my dear I own
three properties they are in that land
of Georgia and you got in sure you do or
two
BMAC Kia's great I'll JB bad make sure
you got them be beating them off or well
note that make sure you like it so you
won't spend your money on it make sure
you take your time and don't just go get
the change so when you get your first
check I stack that [ __ ] up these how you
like a horn to horn then go buy your
time I'll go buy no chain with 20
$30,000 [ __ ] up
[Music]